the best roads always drop on the day
they get the dead late hi I'm Greg the
dark tower official trailer we finally
get one let's get into this but before I
do that I wanted to give a quick shout
out to all our friends over at patreon
our patreon community has been growing
I've been loving all the exclusive video
content we've been putting up over there
even had a Google hangout session that
really was so much fun garroted Rosa
Parra you two are beautiful people we
got another one coming up the responses
in the support over there have been so
amazingly fantastic and heart
overwhelming whatever the word is for it
so when you get the chance please go
over and check out our patreon become up
patron Jex would ever need to come up
with a better thing to name the people
on YouTube and the people of a rep a
tree on anyway the dark tower trailer
man if this films been a work in
progress
thousands of generations the guns do
some nice
yes but my KDS vision basically you see
Eiffel Tower
plain black liquor soup we do scream -
no you don't you realize
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you you here comes dinner right there
are no not anymore
why would you want to destroy towers the
power protects both our walls if it
falls how will be unleashed
he's got the sell roses no see worse you
can't stop it coming that always win
your world might gone the mine is me you
let that help all the people buy guns
what's in your wallet
yeah let's go
you clone your hair did you get the kid
who ever walks with you guys by my end
and silent like that without killing the
both of us I have two openings and I
forgot my phases father I aimed my by
[Music]
with my hands
[Music]
I do not kill with my gun I I kill of my
own
cool Wow
that looks really sweet it's like it's
like a Western sci-fi or element thing
for my basic understanding of what this
movie is I hear it's not based on like
one specific book out of the you know I
think it was like seven or eight Dark
Tower books I think the director said
that this is actually being treated like
a sequel to the books which is really
cool watching this trailer and what
information I read up on about it it may
be good I don't want to read the book so
I usually read non-fiction books I don't
really read them any fiction because I
watch so much fiction through TV and
movies already three or when I read
already nonfiction to keep educating
myself as far as this trailer goes it
doesn't really seem like it you know cuz
it's same based on the books like
Stephen King it doesn't really seem to
have a Stephen King element to it this
looks like more of a full-blown sci-fi
Western accent film and the action does
look really cool I love any kind of
western action with like revolvers or
magnums try and act like I know guns
right now but you know whenever they
have the barrel to come out and then
they have like cool ways of reloading my
favorite shot of the action trailer was
what he's just like just throwing the
bullets and they're super quick or
moment in movies when they capture
bullets midair should like loaded there
while the bullets are in the air all
that shit's really cool idris elba looks
super badass he's one of those actors
who we've seen a lot in a lot of great
TV he's been in a lot of movies where
he's like the standout character Pacific
Rim he's not the main lead character
that's like the biggest movie I could
think of that he stars in that in the
jungle book and Pacific Rim he's like
the best actor in that
whole film here he's the top billed
actor he's the mainly the gunslinger and
for my understanding from what Stephen
King uh said about the gunslinger
character that he is similar to Mammon
Oh named character from like the good
the bad and the ugly fitfully dollar and
you do get that vibe that wandering
mysterious cowboy who's going to help
out on this bigger mission and you know
this is a huge movie it does remind me
of a couple lower budget things it kind
of reminds me a preacher on TV and I
mean I read a couple of the Congress of
preacher to so it doesn't run me a
little bit of preacher it kind of
reminds me of that about that Nicholas
Cage movie Drive Angry
especially with Matthew McConaughey's
character Matthew McConaughey that dude
looks like he's having a total blast
with this role he just looks like a
straight-up bad guy and to me it's
pretty cool to see him play
straightforward villainous character he
doesn't really look scary in this
trailer but if there's one element I'd
like to I would like to see a little bit
more infused in the Dark Tower even
though I haven't read the books but you
know it's from Stephen King it with the
story and I would like to see more of
its horror mystery elements played up
more because right now it's more of a
sci-fi action film with western elements
I would like to see the horror amped up
because I think that would also aid in
clearing Matthew McConaughey's character
like it's it's really cool to me that
ADRA's Elba and Matthew McConaughey are
both starring in a film together playing
opposite good versus bad for all the
people have been wanting interest Elba
to play Bond
I feel like this movie if it does do
well we don't sometimes you just don't
know sometimes the movie flops and you
think it's going to be huge if this
movie does do well and people really
love interest elbows role in it I'd
imagined that maybe we could get some
serious consideration for him to be bond
I guess if I had a concern out of this
whole trailer because this looks like a
super entertaining flick what I'm
thinking though is this this film could
be one of those big huge budget films
that could have a lot more depth to it
right now I'm not getting a sense of
depth like for me the death is coming
from elements that are coming from like
some of the cool element of The Dark
Tower you know the gunslinger
look people looking for the tower what
with the towers capable of allowing you
to control but this looks a lot more
plot heavy and more action heavy and
looks kind of like a superhero film to
be honest I can't necessarily express
too much concern or worry because I
haven't read the actual source material
this is based on but with hearing what
the plot elements are and knowing that
it's a pretty long book series with some
serious devoted fans I'd imagine that
there's a lot more story depth to it
than just a really cool plot with some
action with a lot of cool action in it
like I didn't imagine Roland was a he's
got a little superhero hood think like
the character portrayal in terms of the
performance the dialogue the way
interest elbows coming across is all
really strong but he's a little
superhero like with all the flippin
bullets and [ __ ] as cool as it looks
it's not what I imagined he would be
like from everything I read up on they
had that cold moment of a rolling you
know shoots the bullet with his eyes
closed and I like that line of I don't
shoot with my hand I shoot with my heart
it's a really cool line but it's pretty
lazy come on because Stephen King likes
to go for the weird he likes to have
horror and fantasy elements included in
his stories right now it's just one
trailer can't base an entire movie off
of that alone you know you've got to
sell the tickets especially when you're
throwing down this much money for
production budget and actors it says
right now it looks pretty simple good
versus bad looking for the Dark Tower is
probably going to be some huge climactic
showdown at the end between the two
characters that's what this is looking
like it will play out I could be wrong
it probably am it shouldn't happen in
trailer you got it so spectacle you got
it so excitement but I'm really hoping
that you get some really cool character
in here but you did yourself and the boy
imagined is going to be like father-son
elements here Matthew McConaughey I'm
look like he's having fun not too sure
what he's doing with the role because
from what I'm getting from the trailer
it can be hard with a character like
that to come up with a lot of depth to
that but it's Matthew McConaughey so I
expect nothing less than to have much
more depth to a performance that a lot
of actors would probably just give a
two-dimensional performance to and while
this shows capitalized on its action I
hope the next trailer we get capitalizes
more on story and characters
makes my investment fully in that
because right now the only character I
really give a [ __ ] about is role anyway
guys thanks for saying that was out you
can subscribe to the real rejects follow
me on the social of the media's and go
check out our patreon have a lot of
beautiful family and friends over there
right now got exclusive content up there
goes